reading quotes and life lessons is like
conversing with the finest minds of past
centuries and what could be better than
a conversation with one of the most
brilliant and wise men in modern history
Mark Twain
turn knowledge into an advantage with
these life lessons
kindness is a language which the deaf
can hear
and the blind can see
never allows someone to be your priority
while allowing yourself to be their
option
be careful about reading Health books
you may die of a misprint
the more I learn about people the more I
like my dog
whenever you find yourself on the side
of the majority
it is time to pause and reflect
anger is an acid that can do more harm
to the vessel in which it is stored
than to anything on which it is poured
always acknowledge fault frankly
this will throw those in Authority off
guard and give you an opportunity to
make a choice
if you tell the truth you don't have to
remember anything
noise proves nothing
often a hen who has laid an egg cackles
as if she had laid an asteroid
wrinkles should merely indicate where
the smiles have been
the truth must be served like a coat and
not thrown in the face like a wet towel
the man who does not read has no
advantage over the man who cannot read
a baker is a fellow who lends you his
umbrella when the sun is shining
but wants it back the minute it begins
to rain
keep away from people who try to
belittle your ambitions
small people always do that
but the really great make you feel that
you too
can become great
men will do many things to get himself
loved
he will do all things to get himself
envied
always obey your parents
when they are present
this is the best policy in the long run
because if you don't
they will make you
only two things we'll regret on Deathbed
that we are a little loved
and little traveled
we lavish gifts upon children
but the most precious gift our personal
association which means so much to them
we give grudgingly
eat a live frog first thing in the
morning
and nothing worse will happen to you the
rest of the day
clothes make the man
naked people have little or no influence
in society
when I was a boy of 14
my father was so ignorant I could hardly
stand to have the old man around
but when I got to be 21
I was astonished at how much the old man
had learned in seven years
by land
they're not making it anymore
never argue with a fool
onlookers may not be able to tell the
difference
giving up smoking is the easiest thing
in the world
I know because I've done it thousands of
times
when your friends begin to flatter you
on how young you look
it's a sure sign you're getting old
do something every day that you don't
want to do
this is the golden rule for acquiring
the habit of doing your duty without
pain
the only way to keep your health is to
eat what you don't want
drink what you don't like
and do what you'd rather not
[Music]
the most important days in your life
on the day you are born
and the day you find out why
of all the animals man is the only one
that is cruel
he is the only one that inflicts pain
for the pleasure of doing it
never argue with stupid people
they will drag you down to their level
and then beat you with experience
circumstances make man
not man's circumstances
let us live so that when we come to die
even the Undertaker will be sorry
everyone is a moon
and has a dark side which he never shows
to anybody
concerning the difference between man
and the jackass
some observers hold that there isn't any
man will do many things to get himself
loved
he will do all things to get himself
envied
when you fish for love bait with your
heart nod your brain
no woman or man really knows what
perfect love is
until they have been married a quarter
of a century
do right and you will be conspicuous
a man should not be without morals
it is better to have bad morals than
none at all
be good and you will be lonesome
better a broken promise than none at all
I am an old man and have known a great
many troubles
but most of them never happened
courage is resistance to fear
Mastery of fear not absence of fear
all you need in this life is ignorance
and confidence
then success is sure
forgiveness is the fragrance that the
Violet sheds on the heel that has
crushed it
the fear of death follows from the fear
of life
a man who lives fully is prepared to die
at any time
to get the full value of joy
you must have someone to divide it with
nothing so needs reforming as other
people's habits
the human race has only one really
effective weapon
and that is laughter
in order to make a man or a boy covet a
thing
it is only necessary to make the thing
difficult to attain
grief can take care of itself
but to get full value of a joy you must
have somebody to divide it with
it is better to deserve honors and not
have them than to have them and not
deserve them
there is no sadder sight than a young
pessimist
whatever a man's age he can reduce it by
several years by putting a bright
colored flower in his buttonhole
when people do not respect us we are
sharply offended
yet in his private heart
no man respects himself much
the lack of money is the root of all
evil
a truth is not hard to kill
a lie told well is immortal
Patriot
the person who can holler the loudest
without knowing what he is hollering
about
all say
how hard is it that we have to die
a strange complaint coming from the
mouths of people who have had to live
foreign
the same sum is a bitterness when you
expect more
there are not enough morally brave men
in stock
we are out of moral courage material
there are several good protections
Against The Temptations
but the surest is cowardice
in certain trying circumstances
urgent circumstances desperate
circumstances
profanity furnishes a relief denied even
to prayer
life is short
Break The Rules forgive quickly
kiss slowly
love truly laugh uncontrollably
and never regret anything that makes you
smile
a lie can travel Halfway Around the
World
while the truth is putting its shoes on
I have found out that there ain't no
sure a way to find out whether you like
people or hate them than to travel with
them
loyalty to Country always
loyalty to government
when it deserves it
never marry a woman who has had sex with
her own ego
for it'll always take precedence over
you
after all these years
I see that I was mistaken about Eve in
the beginning
it is better to live outside the garden
with her than inside it without her
human pride is not worthwhile
there is always something lying in
weight to take the wind out of it
when in doubt
tell the truth
by trying we can easily learn to endure
adversity
the best way to cheer yourself up
is to try to cheer somebody else up
April 1.
this is the day upon which we are
reminded of what we are on the other
364.
no civilization can be perfect until the
exact equality between men and women is
included
the man who was a pessimist before 48
knows too much
if he is an optimist after it he knows
too little
good breeding consists in concealing how
much we think of ourselves and how
little we think of the other person
an honest man in politics shines more
than he would elsewhere
pessimist The Optimist who didn't arrive
to be busy is man's only happiness
no real gentleman will tell the naked
truth in the presence of the ladies
[Music]
never tell the truth to people who are
not worthy of it
[Music]
be careless in your dress if you must
but keep a tidy soul
do not complain about growing old
it is a privilege denied to many
an intelligent person never shares three
things with anyone
their innermost fears past regrets
and
ultimate excuse for showing up late
it is the little conveniences that make
the real comfort of life
good friends good books and a sleepy
conscience
this is the ideal life